[Music]
we certainly feel as here now with an
exclusive look at true Barrymore coming
to TV and it's not in a way that any of
us would have ever expected no no the
plot is a bit of a shocker the show is
called
Santa Clarita a diet and trust me when I
say it has nothing to do with losing
weight I satisfy all my cravings and I
only eat the foods that deserve it in
the 10 episode Netflix dark comedy a
mysterious illness turns drew from
working mom to an undead California
realtor who craves eating human flesh I
have endless energy and I sleep two
hours a night I get so much done you eat
people I know it's just that I'm so much
more confident I can parallel park in
one move now Drew's daughter's olive in
Frankie definitely won't be watching as
her TV family including work husband
Timothy Olyphant helps satisfy her new
dietary needs by killing people by only
the bad people of course god there's so
many ways to mess up your children oh my
god did you kill someone you should be
having more fun live your best lives
give it the full Oprah there's bite and
it's fun we're really trying to do the
best we can we're gonna take such good
care you
you